tandis que l'an pire d'essence de
monsieur n'aiguise aoshima que nous
avons vu à cannes alors que meszaros
souhaité par à cannes alors j'ai une et
la priorité il a vu ça à paris comme
tout le monde sait il avait sorti faut
que c'était un film n'ont pas bouleversé
l'info d'avoir une en faut beaucoup
bouleversé enfin c'est tout de même un
film non jamais jamais vu ça ne peut pas
dire ça c'est de talent mais tout à
l'heure a fait des distinctions très
juste à mon avis c'est pas un film
sexuelle c'est vraiment un film érotique
ça se passe beaucoup plus d'eux mêmes
dans la tête de ces deux ordres email à
la tête
non mais vraiment ils sont pas possibles
mais est ce que c'est beau et
comprennent rien à rien changé que vous
devez ordre c'est un film à khimki me
qui me touche profondément pour deux
raisons la première sexy peut-être le
premier film véritablement érotique au
sens où je compense homos c'est à dire
où l'essence correspondre à ce qu'on
souhaite
dans une autre partie de son individus
que celle dont parle jean louis borie et
deuxièmement il est évident que cette
reconstitution des estampes érotiques
japonaise dont tout le monde sait que
françois-régis bastide possède une
collection admirable
cette reconstitution des plus
merveilleuses un stand japonais du
xviiie siècle est un enchantement pour
les yeux
or pour moi dans un film d'abord ce qui
compte c'est la plastique
ceci dit le sujet du film c'est quand
l'érotisme touche à la folie et à la
mort est quelqu'un qui traite un tel
sujet et qui ne se casse pas la gueule
eh bien chapeau bon c'est l'opinion de
charançons l'opinion à toi jean non
c'est un film je ne vais sûrement pas
quoi que tu dises a filmé afaq terrible
terrible et moi je alors là est
magnifique et sublime et moi je refusais
fallait la distinction entre sexuelle
érotiques et pornographiques y revienne
un jour sérieusement moi je la refuse
totalement sur moi c'est le lien du port
louis de porno si tout cela vous gêne je
suis désolé de hawijah jour profondément
là-dessus 600 porno qui comprend c'est
une question de clientèle le porno
lorsque c'est pour les travailleurs
immigrés s'il veut c'est vrai pour les
misères aux sexuelle de la maison
hollywood seles et bah c'est qu'on s'est
bien passé pour ce genre là quand ils
savent pas quand il s'agit des cadres de
moyens et supérieurs qui descendra
champs elysées comme on va boire au
marigot le samedi soir
alors on baise sur de mozart dans des
lumières à georges de la tour ne sent
rien à voir avec le film quand on ferme
et n'a aucun rapport avec ce film
quand on fait des fellations sur une
cantate de bach c'est d'érotique bon
mais la paire de fesses sur la mer
il n'y a pas de contrat de bail à temps
et huit mois la paire de fesses reste la
même est ce que je ressens rançon à
l'appel la tête
c'est exactement la même bon pas
conséquences allaient les distinctions
entre sexualité yahia du port bou à
point et c'est tout bon ceci pour dire
que là vous avez a besoin nous
complètement enfin bon vous avez là un
porno sublime